I also want to say this is theirs in the
beginning okay this is that I created a
weapon Oh God
like it I created a weapon in know just
listen and fallout 4 no in real life
it's a weapon it's it works it's
efficient I'm gonna back up now and I
will show you what it is if he pulls out
a gun I keep away from me if you pose
I'm describing to the audio members okay
pulling out underwear my underwear now
oh god no just listening okay just
listen last Wednesday I played
Bakersfield
mmm-hmm it was a show at a bar okay and
when I was on stage I [ __ ] my pants you
know it was like one of those like the
pods and aliens you know when the little
thing comes out and grabs your head you
plug like my butthole was the pot and
egg and a little alien shot out of my
butthole
holy [ __ ] and went into my pants and my
underwears has a brown as a brown [ __ ]
oh my god alright I have washed it
because I've been using this on kalila
he's been he's been threatening to smear
it on my face all week and he's been
chasing me around the house all week
with those god-awful
situational uses yeah what our kind of
argument every time I speak he's like
you want panty treatment yeah yeah yeah
every time I interrupt his video
gameplay like ya know what's good you
want to play games longer this right
here is the best weapon of all I'm
always gonna have this I'm never gonna
wash these right because look at the
[ __ ] that's rich listen you can't see
this is real [ __ ] can you see it on the
camera George and this is and this is it
Wednesday old he was dancing on stage
and he just yeah yeah debris flew out
his ass and I'm almost dead I'm 44 hey
man oh so dark so yeah I know but it's
it you know you know back in the the age
of like the tutors that's what that was
like I would've been dead you would have
been dead I mean people were dying we
earlier than that
yeah I can't believe I'm still alive and
um but I look good my face anyway but I
pretty
what would you
[Music]